[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
est le fruit d'une concertation
transpartizane je la pose au nom des
sénateurs membres du groupe
développement économique de la montagne
que j'ai l'honneur de présider nous
sommes tous vivement inquiets par la
situation économique des stations de ski
et particulièrement les plus petites qui
se trouvent aujourd'hui dans une
situation intenable d'asphyxie
financière du fait de la hausse des
coûts de l'énergie l'ensemble des
activités économiques et industrielles
sont bien évidemment touchées mais
certaines sont plus pénalisées que
d'autres ce qui nécessite un
accompagnement complémentaire de la part
de l'État c'est le cas des domaines qui
Ablain qui subissent actuellement une
double peine tout d'abord les domaines
skiable subissent de par leur activité
une discrimination tarifaire au regard
du mode attribution de la reine prévue
par les textes d'avril à octobre alors
que les plus gros pics de consommation
des domaines ce qui est blanc ont
essentiellement lieu durant la période
hivernale de plus malgré la mise en
oeuvre d'aide appréciée et attendue des
acteurs économiques de la montagne le
dispositif décrètement de la reine vient
sensiblement réduire l'effet amortisseur
de prix attendu ce qui fragilise les
structures et notamment les plus petites
comme les rég de monter mécanique
actuellement plus de 40% des domaines
qui a français ont récemment du
renégocié leur contrat d'électricité
avec des prix vous pouvant être
multipliés par 10 et des pénalités
exorbitantes en cas de rupture anticipée
de nombreux petits domaines se trouvent
donc aujourd'hui au bord de la faillite
et pourrait déposer le bilan si le
gouvernement n'agit pas pour les
collectivités supports de station qui
seraient défaillantes la prochaine étape
laisse peu de doute la mise sous tutelle
par la chambre régionale des contes ce
qui serait dramatique pour tous
l'écosystème montagnards
j'avais alerté le ministre Bruno Le
Maire au mois d'août du risque qui
pesait sur les sur les stations il y a
maintenant urgence comment peuvent-elles
absorber une hausse des coûts de
l'énergie qui passe de 3 à 20% d'un
chiffre d'affaires ainsi j'ai plusieurs
questions
comment comptez-vous adapter les
dispositifs d'aide pour que les
traitement ne viennent plus annuler le
bénéfice des aides et ce notamment pour
les régies de montée mécanique comment
comptez-vous prendre en compte les
spécificités de domaine skiable pour la
future réforme de la reine qu'en est-il
de la possibilité de renégocier les
contrats maintenant que les prix se
stabilisent des annonces ont été faites
il y a quelques semaines qu'en est-il
aujourd'hui